and we use any kind of collagen with the morning shake for joint health.
Again, I'm not a big fan of collagen for cancer patients if your cancer is growing
if your cancer is getting worse than when there is some evidence that collagen might not be the
best thing. But if your cancer is stable, it's not going to, I don't think it's going to cause it
to grow anything like that. I think it's fine to use collagen.
And is it fine to use any kind of collagen? No, I wouldn't say any kind of collagen.
There's just like good supplements, bad supplements, there's probably a lot of
cheap collagen on the market that's poor quality and maybe coming from China.
So you want to get a good brand of collagen from a practitioner, hopefully that is
buy it from the company because nowadays, China is basically, Chinese companies are basically
docking off the labels, they're reprinting the labels. This stuff you're buying on Amazon
is, could be actually just rice powder. So